el más grave error de la humanidad
deja de soñar de imaginar de crear deja
de hacer la diferencia en el mundo hola
dioses o que opinan tengo diez años de
edad y me consideran un activador para
la construcción de un futuro cierto y
feliz a través de la niñez y tengo unas
preguntas para que recuerdas cuando sin
dudarlo hacia la amistad es fácilmente
cuando con sus familias y amigos serán
los héroes los astronautas los
exploradores y mucho más
cuando te divertida sin límites cuando
compartía estas cosas con gusto si eras
muy feliz
y seguro también recordarás que a los
niños nos limitan los entrenos en
nuestra capacidad como adultos nos dicen
que nos hagamos supuestamente para
protegernos que para que no nos las
tenemos puesto ahí que es cuando nos
meten ese miedo a caer a perder a no
poder y es cuando lo dejamos sabiendo
que desde un principio teníamos toda la
seguridad del mundo y si quizá más
faltaba experiencia pero acaso no se
trata de eso de aprender de vivir
lo peor ahora dicen niñas y niños ellas
y ellos que -según para darnos mayores
oportunidades pero que no todos somos
chiquitos y merecemos el mismo trato
porque nos dividen en fin lo dejo aquí
para que lo reflexiones
4 somos niños todo es posible somos
super imaginativos creativos amistosos
confiables podemos hacer amistades a
donde vayamos tenemos la capacidad de
aprender y entender todas esas cosas que
nos transmiten
no llame la atención y cuando haya un
día de lluvia dirán que es más tiempo si
la lluvia es maravillosa alimentar las
plantas ríos mares lagunas y mucho más y
además aquí podemos a mojarse y saltar
en los charcos de agua no para nosotros
un día lluvioso es simplemente un
excelente día cuando no hacemos venimos
al mundo con las mismas oportunidades
los impedimentos han crecido continuamos
pueden irse fortaleciendo y provocando
ruidos y miedos pero no tiene que ser no
tiene que ser así te imaginarías llegar
a tu trabajo estando como niña saludable
a todos sonriendo compartiendo historias
divertidísimas y disfrutando del momento
y pensar john de allí yo te diría
pensaría que eres feliz aunque estés
algún tornillo pero lo importante lo que
compensaría de ti los ojos te atreverías
a hacerlo propongo una pequeña dinámica
sonríe a la persona de tu alrededor
nos saludamos
[Música]
dales un pequeño abrazo
como se sintieron se excluyera un bien
lo disfrutaron
para continuar y ser carles un poquito
sobre lo que estoy haciendo actualmente
soy reconocida por diferentes organismos
tanto por naciones unidas como por
diferentes premios como lo son tweets
pérez de la sostenibilidad e innovación
turística con el primer lugar en la
categoría
eres el futuro compitiendo encontrar una
tesis de muestra y una delegación de
universidades mascletà dable fue
complicado pero lo logramos y otro fue
latinoamérica reales como su nombre lo
dice a nivel latinoamérica y
participando con alrededor de 3.700
concursantes canalizarse lugar en la
categoría bosques y flora donde mejorado
por perteneciente a national geographic
www el banco interamericano de
desarrollo los académicos e
investigadores actualmente tenemos la
popularidad y el disco yo tenemos un
club organizado por la fundación de
naciones unidas donde todas
pueden participar con cómputo más
alcances del jaguar con alrededor de 11
mil hectáreas donados voluntariamente
que tú puedes ir a conocer hemos
platicado con alrededor de 1500 niños
contando a la calle que algunos se
convirtieron en embajadores del pro coco
y se encargan de concientizar a la gente
sobre el cuidado la importancia del
desarrollo sostenible ahora que va a ser
un trato contigo
apoya a la ansiedad si los dueños de los
niños no les hagas pensar que son
arcillas que son pasajeras para que esos
niños no se enfermen inflable mal que es
tan difícil de combatir llamado
desesperanza ayúdame a que se complete
en niños en adultos muy felices
conviviendo con niños aún más todos
podemos hacer lograr cambios nosotros
los niños lo que queremos es que nos
bien lleva se impulsen que crean desde
la niñez activamente podemos forjar
nuestro futuro hoy no sabemos de esperar
a 2030 ó 2050 para que llegue un cambio
debemos de comenzarlo
el futuro de tu hijo sobrino nieto
amiguitos ellos dirán gracias mamá papá
a los amigos lo construimos muy bien
cliente porque con pequeñas acciones
puedes lograr un gran cambio no
necesitas ser extraordinario para
cambiar el universo porque no haces con
el don de soñar imaginar y de crear un
mundo mejor en todos los estilos
entonces
en mi experiencia el más grande error de
la humanidad es dejar de ser niños
vuelve a ser niño hasta siempre
[Aplausos]
[Música]